when Ukrainian troops are pushed Russian
occupiers out of the occupied city of
Herson this November there were scenes
of Celebration but in recent weeks it
has become the target of intensifying
Russian attacks Ukraine's military says
Russia fired 33 rockets at civilian
Targets in the 24 hours going into
Wednesday hundreds of civilians are
fleeing as Russian forces pound
populated areas with mortars and
artillery
is a city slowly being reduced to Rubble
Keith says Moscow was deploying more
tanks and armored vehicles to the area
and further stepping up its aerial
bombardment of the city
people here have already seen more than
their fair share of this brutal War
but in recent days and nights things
have become even worse
this woman says she lost her son in an
overnight raid
I must have felt something would go
wrong in the morning because I urged him
to wake up and leave the house but he
didn't and that was it our lives are
ruined
Russia's Relentless shelling is
destroying Hassan's critical
infrastructure and taking a massive toll
on civilian life
a mortar attack on Christmas Eve killed
11 people and injured dozens more among
the dead a social worker a butcher and a
woman selling Mobile SIM cards everyday
civilians at the city's Central Market
some who have held out here now say they
can't take it any longer
they're getting out while they still can
we stayed this whole time and thought it
would pass but when the home next to
ours and my father's home were hit it
was too scary
just last month there were celebratory
scenes in Hesson as Kiev retook the
Regional Center
now it appears Moscow is trying to
retake it either that or simply Raise It
to the Ground
and for more on this story I'm very
pleased to welcome Marina Myron a
postdoctoral researcher at the
department of War studies at King's
College London thank you so much for
taking the time I want to begin by
asking you why her son is such a focus
for the Russian military right now
obviously her son was a slap and to
Putin's face when um the Russian troops
left her son and had to
um switch to defensive positions along
the nearby River so obviously what
Russia is trying to do right now is on
the one hand they want to show that the
Ukrainian forces
um cannot hold it and cannot protect the
citizens living there so they are
basically trying to terrorize the
population so that the people lose
credibility and the power of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces on the one hand
on the other hand and it doesn't it
shouldn't be interpreted as Russia's
attempt to retake her son that would be
strategically unwise because they have
quite solid defensive position along the
river
because they just don't have the
Manpower right now but what they're
trying to do is to pin down Ukrainian
forces in person because the real
fighting is going on somewhere else
around bakmud and around sort of and
criminal and that's basically the major
Focus for the Russians and can you tell
us more about that heavy fighting that
is continuing elsewhere in eastern
Ukraine
yes absolutely so
um there is a very important Road um
connecting swato and criminal and the
the forces the Ukrainian forces have
been trying to make advances in that
region after they have retaken Limon
however it they have not been successful
yet and the Russians are trying to
defend their positions because the the
reason for that it's a key region to go
back to listen chansk and several of the
netsk which Russians have taken so that
that that is a key part maybe in and of
itself those two cities are not
significant but they basically provide
the Ukrainian forces with a possibility
to move and retake more territory and
another place is obviously bakmud was a
PMC Wagner is um trying to take the city
so that's another kind of symbolic City
for Russia because
um when Russia withdrew its troops from
izum the only grouping that remained in
that direction was a Wagner grouping in
bakmut was the idea of taking back mode
to be able to advance toward towards
levanskin chromators so that has another
kind of not just strategic but also a
political meaning
and what about the potential for
diplomacy How likely do you think a
negotiated piece is at this stage given
that the Kremlin has now rejected a
peace plan proposed by Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski
I think right now it's quite difficult
because we have seen the result
um of President zielinski he is not
going to agree to Russia's terms and
Russia is keeping
um its terms it's being pretty firm and
saying basically we are not going to
withdraw forces we're going to place a
long game and so to reach an agreement
right now the end states that both
States and Visage are so fundamentally
different that there can be no agreement
The best scenario we can possibly hope
for in order to stop the whole violence
is to freeze a conflict and that would
mean intervention from Turkey
intervention from other NATO members and
from the United States to freeze the
conflict and to reach some some kind of
a ceasefire however a peace agreement is
not likely to happen anytime soon I want
to thank you so much for taking the time
to share that with us that is Dr Marina
Myron postdoctoral researcher at the
department of War studies College London